- I'd rather die than compromise my gut.
- Hmm.
Yeah.
- It just, it doesn't feel good enough.
Like if you're going to
lose, lose on your own sword.
(upbeat music plays)
- The Gary V Audio Experience
- Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
Super excited for this episode.
As many of you know,
I've become shockingly
selective during COVID
and even right before it
on guests on the podcast.
I've I, you know,
just want to be thoughtful
about what fills these pipes.
And you know, to me,
I want to be selective
on individuals who I
think could bring value
in their stories or their execution.
And today is one of such things.
I'm super excited to
have Jamie on the show.
I'm going to let her introduce herself.
And then I've got a series
of questions because I've been watching
from afar as she's developed
her career and executions.
And I'm excited to share
them with this audience.
I'm sure many of you will
know, but I know many,
many of you won't just,
that's how it always works.
Jimmy, every time I'm on a podcast,
or like everybody knows, I'm
like, eh, and then on Twitter.
(indistinct)
I think people, you know,
there's so much out in the world,
but I know you also have a new book
so that's going to be fun to talk about.
So without further ado,
why don't you tell the
Vayner nation who you are
and what's cooking?
And I know that we'll probably post this
in a couple of days, which is right
before the February 23rd
date, which is exciting.
And so why don't you give us the 411?
- All right.
Well, Gary, thank you
so much for having me.
I'm super excited to share
this big week with you too
and your whole community.
So thank you.
Yeah.
My name is Jamie Kern Lima
and I'm probably most well known,
like if you Google my story,
you'll probably see Denny's waitress
builds billion dollar company.
So I started the company
in my living room called IT Cosmetics
and went through three years of hearing no
from just about everyone in the world,
got down to my last thousand
dollars and kept going,
eventually built that company and sold it
to L'Oreal for over a billion dollars.
And, and, you know, but
that's what you see online
and why I wrote my first
ever book Believe It
is because the real story
behind the story is, you know,
I'm a girl who went from
not believing in myself
to learning how to believe in myself
and like doubting I'm enough
to having to learn to know I'm enough.
And just trying to figure out how
to get through all the setbacks
and kind of step into the
person I was born to be.
So I know that's not just my story,
it's the story of so many
people listening right now,
on their own journeys
of learning to believe
in themselves and trust themselves
and know they're enough.
And so just want to say thank you
to Gary also for all that
you do to inspire everyone
on their own journeys, you know, you kind
of always share the story
behind the story of everything.
So that's why I'm super, super honored
to be part of your show.
- Thank you for saying that.
Let's take a step back
because it is such a
massive accomplishment.
It's like so fun to be on here.
And I think, you know, I've just,
I've been trying to be more thoughtful
about giving more examples of
people who've made it then,
you know, I think we get
into the laziness of,
and they're incredible Elon Musk
or Bezos or Oprah, or, you know,
but I feel like
there's some really crazy
ass stories out there
and yours is one of them.
So if you don't mind to indulge me,
'cause I'm going to enjoy it,
I think it really matters.
I think, you know,
I get hit up all the time by immigrants,
like kids that grew up
that are not good students
in immigrant families
and when they see me, it means something.
I think your story is so
universal with so few,
and I mean so few to get
to the sheer level of financial success.
And I think even the way you set this up
around emotional success
and things of that nature,
more people can get there
and don't need the financial
levels that you've achieved.
But I do think knowing
that this is an entrepreneurial audience,
I do think it's important
to get into a little bit of the details.
'Cause I think you might say one sentence
that might inspire somebody
to persevere because you know,
you went with a macro
down to a thousand bucks,
like there's some real stuff
there, like break this down,
like give me five minutes
of how you came up with the
company idea and then like,
and then like 12
or 13 highlights of the
path of how it went down.
- Yeah, sure.
So, you know I,
it's so funny 'cause I was
working as a journalist,
which I thought was my dream job.
Ever since I was a little girl,
I would watch Oprah every single day Gary
and I thought, oh my gosh,
I want to spend my life
telling other people's stories.
Like I knew that was what I
was going to do my whole life.
And so I was what I thought was working
in my dream job as a news anchor.
And then I got a skin
condition called rosacea,
and I learned there's no cure for it.
And I would be anchoring the news live
and what would start
to happen is my my cheeks
would get so bright red
and inflamed that the makeup
would start to break up
and this redness would come through.
And so I went through this season
in my life that I thought was
a setback, like a big setback.
I would be anchoring the news live
and I'd hear from my producer
in my earpiece, who was
just trying to have my back.
And they'd be like, there's
something on your face,
there's something on your
face, you need to wipe it off,
you need to wipe it off.
And I knew there was
nothing I could wipe off.
And so I went through
this sort of like struggle
with confidence, with inner critic stuff,
thinking am I going to get fired?
Am I going to lose ratings?
But in that set, in
that season of setback,
like I didn't realize it was actually,
well so many times our setbacks
are really our set ups,
right, for something
that we're supposed to actually do.
And I started just trying
to find any makeup product
that would work and I
realized nothing would.
And I realized that
when you see ads on TV,
you typically just see models
with perfect skin or they
are all photo shopped.
- What year is this?
Set this up for everybody.
- Yeah.
So this is 2007 is when
this started happening.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
And I kind of thought,
okay, I'm in my dream job.
But I started getting
this gut feeling like,
what if I could figure out how
to make a product that worked for me?
It'd probably helped a whole
lot of other people too.
But I sat there in this weird spot
and maybe a lot of people
are in the spot now where-
- I've lost you with some
people are in this weird spot.
- Yep.
- Go ahead.
Went too far ahead?
Okay great.
- We, I love, like I'm
not one of these posts,
you know, back to imperfections.
- Yeah.
- You know, I think it's crazy
when people like start from the beginning
or like the audience listening,
like I don't know for everybody
who's listening at home right now,
but I have a funny feeling
that Zoom and Stream
Yard and Google Hangouts
or FaceTime has frozen
for everybody many times
over the last year or so,
we will put some funny music over that.
Keep going.
We kind of lost you at the
point where you were like,
I found myself in this funny spot.
- Yeah.
I thought, you know, I was
in a season of setback and
really it was a set-up.
So I was in a spot though
where my gut was telling me, like,
you need to do this.
You need to go after it.
But my head was saying,
you're not qualified.
You have almost no money.
You have no connections.
Like, you know, I knew nothing Gary
about how do I start at a beauty company?
Like I had no idea.
But you know, when I
look back at everything,
I just want to share this with
you and your whole audience
because I think we're
in this culture a lot of times
where it's like, don't quit.
Whatever you do, just don't quit.
Don't quit, don't quit.
And I think the victory
isn't when you don't quit.
I think the victory is
when you're able to tune in
and hear your own gut
and know like sometimes
knowing when to let go
of a dream is as important as
knowing when to go after one.
And in that moment, I thought
I was in my dream job.
I thought my whole life I,
this is what I want to do is
share other people's stories.
And all of a sudden,
I just had this gut feeling
like I'm supposed to quit
what I thought was my dream job
and start this crazy
entrepreneurial journey
that didn't make sense in my head.
It just made sense in my gut.
And when I look back over
so many of these moments,
I feel like listening to my gut is like,
those are the moments
that change our lives.
- Do you think intuition
is grossly misunderstood
and underrated?
- I think it's misunderstood
because I think that we have
so much noise around us.
I believe Gary, like
every person listening,
whether they're 12 years
old or 112 years old,
I think we all have intuition
that like a knowing inside of us
and I think our knowing is always right.
I think our knowing is-
- Can I, I'm sorry finish.
- No, no, no, I was gonna say,
I think our knowing
is more powerful even
than anyone else's advice.
But I think that we have
so much noise around us,
from other people's opinions
to our own self doubt, right?
That it gets so loud.
We start to not even be able
to hear our own intuition anymore.
So most people haven't even
heard their own intuition
in a long time, or they don't know how.
- I would tell you that I
couldn't applaud that POV more.
It is my belief that my
happiness, which matters
to me the most and then comma
my success, which I have pride
in my professional
life, is 100% predicated
on my inability to
compromise my intuition.
I believe intuition is
uncomfortably misunderstood.
I believe that A students
and very narrow kind of rigid thinkers,
which most people are,
have demonized intuition.
I think intuition is
looked upon as careless
and is positioned as silly
or flaky or whatever
else you want to call it.
And I will tell you that
it is basically something
that I've started exploring with myself.
And I believe it is a category
of information that I
will talk a lot more about
because basically everything good
that I've decided that has gone on
to be very very good
has been far more based
on intuition than anything else.
- I, you know, I have the
exact same experiences,
like how I broke through this
crazy crowded beauty space
and built something that
ended up passing all
of the companies.
I used to save my tip money
as a Denny's waitress to buy
in department stores was
literally figuring out how
to hear my own intuition
and then trust it.
That's the other part of it.
Right?
And like, I love that
you're talking about this.
And by the way, for so many people,
that's how they hear God or their faith,
whatever faith they practice, right?
Or even the universe,
they hear it through their own intuition.
And I think it's like, I
think it's your super power.
That's what I think.
I think that it's literally the one thing
that changes everything
that if I were an entrepreneur
or even just someone that
wanted to go after a dream
or I mean,
that's the biggest thing
I would focus on is
how do I tune into and hear my own gut
and how do I differentiate
that from all the noise
around or other people?
- What is your intuition?
Funny.
I do say that a lot.
I just realized.
What is your intuition
on the other ingredient needed
for this to actually work,
which is the ability to be
comfortable with failure?
Because I'll tell you the reason I'm
in love with my intuition
is a couple of reasons.
One, humility.
My intuition has been the
driver of so much success.
It has also led to many failures.
It is my capacity to be comfortable
in my micro failure that has allowed me
to continuously trust my intuition.
Thoughts?
- Yeah.
Thoughts are, okay,
I'm going to say something
you might freak out over.
Or-
- No, I'm excited.
- I think every time your
intuition leads you to a failure,
I don't think it's a failure.
I think it's part of your destiny
and your destined and
your serendipitous journey
where you had to build that muscle
in order to carry the weight
- of your success.
- So, can I stop you?
Because I don't think that's crazy at all.
I actually, it makes me want
to ask you something else.
Do you believe that your
optimism in your blood
and soul is also an required ingredient
to make what we're
talking about here work?
Because what I'm thinking
about is the people on
the other side, right?
And now they're listening
to two successful people
talk about intuition
and they're basically
saying fuck these two.
Like, okay, good.
But like you guys got lucky.
And I know that I know a million people
that have quote unquote got lucky
in different levels of
success financially,
but have happiness of their journey.
But it is ingredients.
It's a concoction.
It is not a straight like,
it's kind of like diseases, right?
It's never like, oh pepper.
No.
It's like, for example,
with COVID I hear like, it's this thing
and then the zinc can get
in it's mixtures right?
HIV, right?
It was a cocktail, I'm
listening carefully to you.
We want intuition.
Now what I want to know,
then we went with capacity to
be comfortable with failure.
AKA humility.
Now I'm asking you because your answer
is like, no, no, Gary,
let me send you a different way.
And I'm with you on this.
I see them as micro failures.
But to your point, life
is so serendipitous,
you just don't know, you know,
but I'm fascinated by your next,
the next statement, which looks like this.
Do you believe that your
optimism allows us all to work?
Because if you are
looking at losses as in,
well this was meant to be part
of my journey and this
scar is actually attractive
because that's how I think about it.
I think about all those losses of scars
and like that scar giving you a character
and that's attractive.
Do you believe that optimism
was an incredibly big factor
and ingredient in your success?
- I think optimism is great.
I think though
that knowing why we're
doing what we're doing,
listening to our gut and
going after our calling,
like literally living our calling,
I think that's the victory.
- Hold on though.
Here's an interesting question.
Every human needs levels of
affirmation along the way
to sustain that.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And so,
in the beginning where you're
not seeing those results,
for many and not, you might've, you know,
I've always seen results pretty
quickly in my good calls.
So I always try to think about
someone who's not seeing it.
So because they don't have
optimism, they have delusion
and they think they're
going to be, you know,
Beyonce when they can't sing.
Right?
Do you feel like the, you know,
believing in your calling
gets affirmed along the way.
What do you rely on in that beginning?
Don't you think blind faith is
actually completely grounded
in optimism?
- I mean, for me, my faith
is a huge part of my life.
- I'm sorry.
I'm going to take religion as faith out.
- Sure.
- I'm saying I was, you know,
I'm just thinking about you, young you
in this moment and I'm
really fascinated by it.
I'm meant to do this
because what you're talking
about is what I love which is the journey.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- I'm trying to get into
your, go ahead please.
- Yeah yeah.
I was gonna say, I don't think
the victory is the outcome.
Right?
I don't think the victory, listen,
I know how accomplished
you are in everything.
I know you're going to have
the New York Jets one day.
I know all that, but I don't
think that's the victory.
I think the victory is the journey
of actually like stepping
into all of who you are
and not talking yourself
out of your own truth.
And what I mean by that is this journey
that we're talking about, right?
Of course optimism, of course resiliency
to get back up every
time you're knocked down.
Of course all those things.
But I think that so many
people listening right now,
if they don't ever learn to get still
and hear their own truth and
hear their own intuition,
I think what's going to happen,
and this is what happens to most people
is they end up at staying
in their comfort zone.
They end up putting their
own immediate failures
on a pedestal or other people's
opinions or self doubt.
They end up talking to themselves
out of their own truth.
And then they end up never actually
becoming the person they're born to be.
So for me,
I don't think like the
fact that I was able
to build a billion dollar
company is the victory.
I think the moments
of me knowing this is
what I'm supposed to do
and trusting it, even when
it doesn't make sense.
And I'll give you one example, okay?
- Please.
- So, and maybe this will make sense.
'Cause optimism of course is important.
And I know what you're saying,
but I think the biggest
thing is learning how
to hear yourself and trust yourself.
I really believe that.
There was a moment-
- How do you define that as a term?
Because I view that as
self-belief and confidence
and optimism.
I'm just,
I think that you're such
a, you know, very quickly,
I'm like, oh, okay, this is my sister.
Like literally within
the first few seconds.
Like oh I see, oh I see.
- I just-
- I was wanting to do and I apologize,
I'm hoping a different voice
might do this for the listener.
I'm trying to figure out what
words you use to quantify.
I fully agree with you,
everything you're saying.
I'm wondering if you view optimism as,
so I think optimism similar
to what we were talking
about earlier sometimes
gets pegged as delusion.
- Hmm, yeah.
Okay.
- See where I'm going?
Because I could always feel
you doing that right now.
And I'm like, I get you sister
because like this isn't why I,
like it's so crazy,
wordsmithing matters, right?
Like for example hustle
has gotten demonized as like burnout.
So I no longer use it
'cause I don't need it.
You know what I'm going
to call it, work ethic,
call it what you want.
Here's what I can tell you.
For all the belief you had
and all the love you had in
doing what you were doing,
I'm a pretty confident
based on your outcome
that there was a lot of work ethic there.
And so whatever you want to call it.
And sometimes I just think about,
I know the word hustle triggers people.
So I use the word work ethic now
because I don't want
to ever not let anybody
who cares to listen to me not realize that
if you don't put in the
work, it is impossible.
Thoughts on that?
- Yeah.
I agree with that.
And I just had a big aha moment
that what you're saying is optimism.
I a billion percent agree with.
And I'm thinking
of that right now as belief.
Same thing.
Yep.
And now I'm right there with you.
Like here's the thing when,
and then I want to share
one quick story with you too
that I hopefully,
someone listening right
now maybe needs to hear.
But I mean when I look back, it's like,
when people are like,
oh, how did you start
with close to nothing and
build a billion dollar company?
It's like, yeah, I got, you know,
I got back up every
time I got knocked down
and I followed my gut and I
worked really, really hard.
But I do think that one
of the most important
things I did was just,
like how to build a billion
dollar company from nothing.
Like I think one of the
most important things
is making that decision
to believe that you can.
- Yes.
- And for me, that's optimism,
exactly what you're saying.
And I guess I call it belief.
So yeah, a million percent with that.
And one more thing just on,
maybe people listening to
us right now, they're like,
oh Gary, like Jamie, I, you know,
I trust my gut sometimes and
it's wrong or I tried it once
and it didn't work or I
don't know how, you know,
don't know how to hear my own intuition.
I just want to say I think
that it is a muscle that we can all build.
And I think people have
to give themselves grace.
Right?
It's almost, it reminds
me of like, when you start
to meditate, a lot of people
try it and they can't do it.
They're like they go
through their to-do list
in their head the whole
time they tried to meditate,
but you have to like give
yourself grace and start.
And you know what I would say,
whether it's entrepreneurs
or someone who's 14 years old
and out there dating
right now, I would say,
when you start to look
back at your experiences
and think about moments
when you had a gut feeling
and you didn't follow it,
like we've all dated like a sketchy guy
or like a sketchy girl
or had like, and like, you're like,
you know his phone didn't
really just disappear,
like shut off for three days
and he didn't lose the phone.
He was like, you know,
and then you kind of make
that decision of like, okay.
- Well talk to me about, I
mean, we are really vibing here.
Actually I want to talk to you offline.
'Cause I just have had the thought.
Talk to like,
I'm starting to wrap but I'm so excited.
Insecurity.
- Yeah.
- Right?
'Cause you're like, to me, like thinking
to my girlfriends, friends that were girls
that were dating guys
that I knew what the guys
were doing, which was,
they were preying on my
friend's insecurities
and sometimes brilliant, beautiful girls.
And I'm like, this fucking sucks.
This woman, it really
triggered something in me.
This woman I'm thinking
about four or five friends,
through the last 20 years,
this woman is subjectively,
and if we had a hundred people ask
is a million miles better than this man.
This man has figured out the cheat code
that if he makes her feel
insecure, he has the leverage.
Thoughts?
- Yep.
I think that happens every single day.
And I think that we look for people
that treat us how we believe
we deserve to be treated,
like we find partners that-
- So you go with cool.
Before you worry about jerk
off Johnny, this is a big game
of your own lack of self-love towards you.
- It's your own lack of self-love
because here's the thing.
And I don't know your friends.
So I'll just say this, I'll
make a general statement.
- I appreciate this.
This was mainly 17 to 25 years old
'cause you see that so commonly there.
I mean in later stages, you know,
people are in really deep relationships
and you're in different
parts of your life.
When you're going through
high school and college,
you're spending so much time with people,
you get better reads to the
cleanness of the data is like,
oh this is really fucked up.
When you're older, you're
running in different circles.
You don't really get to see it as easily.
- Right.
And I think that whether, you know,
no matter your age,
this is what I believe.
I think that when someone's
treating us like crap
and we stay with them,
I think it's because it's,
we deep down inside don't
believe we deserve better yet.
And here's the thing for people like that
that are dating your friend
who's totally screwing them over, right?
If you were to bring
the best, most amazing,
beautifully like kind
person into their space,
that same girl would probably put them
in the friend zone.
- I couldn't agree more.
- Yeah, because-
(indistinct)
- And also, people value different things
through their life.
You know, one of the things,
you know, right now we lived
through a generation
desperately interested
in blaming social media
for lack of accountability.
They're just pointing fingers, right?
Like if you are in a
good place with yourself
and your perspective is
strong around gratitude,
an anonymous person's
negative comment is not going
to ruin your day.
- Yeah.
And I think when it does,
I think that's what's so tough.
Right?
That's when it's a reminder
to ourselves like, oh yeah,
we have some more work to do.
One of the things I talk
about in my book Believe It
is just that ability to learn
to turn down the volume on certain things
and turn up the volume on
other things like one example,
we were three years into
building the company.
Right?
I just hear no from everyone, Gary,
like all the retailers I dreamed
of carrying our products
that I used to shop in.
Right?
I would save my tip money,
like I mentioned as a Denny's waitress
and buy products at the department stores.
- And what year was this?
- So we launched 2007.
Like I quit my job 2007.
I wrote the business plan
on my honeymoon flight to South Africa
with my husband,
not the most romantic way
to kick off a marriage.
And we both got back, quit
our jobs, dove all in.
I thought Gary and maybe so
many entrepreneurs listening.
I thought, oh, if I just
pour everything I have
and actually create a product that works,
like it's just going to sell.
If it's that good, it's
just going to sell.
And then I didn't realize
it would be the heart.
I mean, I've had a lot of jobs in my life,
but being an entrepreneur is by far.
- And you especially also built
that brand different than
building a brand today
where you can use Shopify
and social media to build it.
You had to get a yes from
Sephora, Ulta, you know, Walmart,
Walgreens, and Macy, whoever it was.
And that is difficult
when you're innovating the way you did.
Do you know that my whole life is no,
you know VaynerMedia?
A lot of people listening don't know this.
Most brands don't want to
say yes to VaynerMedia.
We don't want to do a
commercial and then go to sleep.
Like we don't want to take 12 weeks
to do the perfect commercial
and then do print ads that look like it
or banner ads or digital programmatic.
My whole life building VaynerMedia is no.
Everything I do is Gary V's easy.
I just do it with the audience.
But VaynerMedia is exactly,
I know what you're living through because
when you innovate and you're
doing something different
and you don't look the part,
you didn't work at Proctor
and Gamble for 13 years,
I'm like what's this
Washington State thing.
Like they, you know, you know what it is.
- Well, and it's wild.
'Cause I would go in and start, you know,
I would pitch the product and you know,
we were staying alive on social media.
So we were getting people
who were writing just blogs
at that point.
And we were selling like
one to three orders a day
on our website and people
were spreading the word.
That was the only way
we barely stayed alive,
but all the retailers,
exactly what you said.
And by the way, I've learned this,
like when you're doing
something that's authentic
or that is different.
But even if it's just authentic to you,
even in a crowded industry, by definition,
it's novel, by definition
has never been done before.
And I really believe looking back now
at this journey and every,
I believe that like, even
a lot of visionaries,
taught visionaries.
I think they can't imagine
anything being successful
unless subconsciously they have proof
in the back that they've
already seen it in.
It's already worked.
So it's like, of course, so
many people are going to say no
to your dream or doubt your dream
if they've never seen it done before.
And we had three years
of every single beauty retailer saying no,
you're not the right fit.
It's not gonna work.
You're not right for our customers.
And I kept, and by the way,
we talk about gut feeling.
I kept having this gut
feeling we're supposed
to go on QVC because then,
I could actually like
show my bright red rosacea
and prove live that our product works
unlike the Photoshop ads on TV.
And this is just something
to share for someone
who might need to hear this right now
who's having a gut feeling,
but they keep feeling like they're wrong.
Look, I kept having this feeling.
And every time I would
do a meeting with QVC,
it would be a no.
Every phone call I'd finally get,
like I got their head guy,
Alan Burke on the phone.
He's like a legend.
He's responsible
for building this billion
dollar beauty empire on QVC.
And I finally got him
on a call and I thought,
for sure it was going to be a yes.
And because if he he's
taking his precious time
and it was about a minute
into the call and he said,
"I just need to let you know,
we've reviewed your product
with all the buyers.
It's unanimous.
It's a, no, you're not
the right fit for QVC."
And of course I like poured out my heart.
And I'm like, oh, but I am the right fit.
And then I, you know,
we were down a hundred thousand dollars
in our bank account at that point.
So I remember like crying myself to sleep.
And long story short,
a year later when I finally
did get a yes to go on QVC,
I took this big risk
that I was advised not to by consultants.
And I put real women of all shapes
and sizes and skin tones
and skin challenges.
And I showed my own bare face
and all the things that
had never been done before,
we sold out at the 10 minute mark.
I was crying on national
television because it's live,
QVC is live to a hundred million homes.
- You knew the truth and
your heart would win.
Not, you know, students
telling you what to do.
- Yeah.
You know, and listen, it was a big risk,
but I feel like I know this
lesson that like, I know this
and now I've seen it play out
with thousands of entrepreneurs
over the years, but I know
that authenticity alone
doesn't guarantee success,
but in authenticity guarantees failure.
- Love that, love that.
Listen, you are preaching.
I'd rather die.
I'd rather die than compromise my gut.
- Yeah.
- It just doesn't feel good enough.
Like if you're going to
lose, lose on your own sword.
Worst thing in the world
to do is to lose based
on somebody else's advice.
I really believe that.
- Yes.
And you know what else
to that, don't think,
don't even necessarily think,
cause you're losing right now
that you've lost and
what I mean by that it-
- Go ahead, I'm sorry.
- Yeah.
Oh no.
I was going to see Gary like,
like, so this is wild, right?
So Alan Burke, the guy I just mentioned.
After we finally got onto QVC.
So he's the guy that said
no, I cried myself to sleep.
After we got onto QVC,
that one airing turned
into five that year,
101 the next year.
And then I did over 250 live
shows a year for eight years
in a row.
And we built the largest
beauty brand in QVC's history.
So it is right now at this
moment that you and I are talking
and when Alan Burke
retired and he, by the way,
he ended up being, becoming
one of my greatest mentors
after we launched on QVC.
He's so brilliant, to be honest.
And after he retired,
we actually hired him
in a paid position on our
advisory board at IT Cosmetics.
So the guy who rejected
me is now working for me.
- I love that.
First of all, it's amazing.
I need a much more interesting one.
At his retirement dinner,
did he publicly say that
you were his biggest miss?
And later-
- So here's the funny
thing he would say that.
And he has said that,
but here's what I know.
I know that had he said yes sooner,
I know that I didn't
know what I didn't know.
Had he said yes sooner we
would have failed because-
- You think so?
- I do because what I learned later-
- As somebody who's so
intuitive, why do you not believe
that a year earlier you would
have gone with your gut?
- I would have, but at the time
and maybe this was just
serendipitous grace,
but at the time, what I
learned later was we, you know,
that QVC is massive, right?
Like the one airing I got,
I had to sell 6,000 units
in 10 minutes to hit the
sales goal or not come back.
What I learned later was like,
had he said yes any sooner,
we were not operationally
sophisticated enough
to handle an account that
size on the back end.
So maybe that was just serendipity grace.
- I see.
You might've sold them upfront
but logistically you were not prepared.
- Right, yeah.
And so I feel like that was
divine timing in that case.
And you know, one other
thing to share too, just,
and by the way I knew in my gut,
we were supposed to be on QVC,
but for three years they said no, right?
And then we ended up building
the biggest beauty brand
in QVC's history.
And I just want to share that
because I know there's
people listening right now
that think like, oh,
I'm listening to my gut,
I feel strongly, but I
have no proof around me
that my business is succeeding
or that I'm not getting
the traction I want
or I'm not getting-
- Can I throw something at you?
'Cause we're running out of time here.
As a matter of fact,
this is pissing me off.
I'm sorry.
I have this hardcore meeting
that I'm already late for.
Everyone, this is what sucks
about actually being a businessman,
not a content producer
when every time you like,
I'm trying to be better
about not interrupting,
even though I got excited here
and I know I interrupted many times.
Couple things.
One, give everybody your handles.
'Cause I have a feeling a bunch
of new fans were just created.
So I want to make sure they follow you
so they can continue
journey to Vayner nation.
I'm telling you, this
is very obvious to me.
You have to buy this book,
which is coming out now,
or you should pre, like,
I feel like we're going to
air this in a couple of days,
which is probably a day or
two before the book comes out,
which I think is the 23rd.
So you should definitely go
to Amazon or Barnes and Nobles
and pre-order it or order it immediately.
Jamie, give the handles and
give the name of the books
so everybody can find it real quick.
- Yeah.
- And then I have one more question.
- Okay.
Thank you.
So Jamie Kern Lima, and I'm
at JamieKernLina on Instagram.
The book is called Believe It.
And there's a ton of free gifts
for this week for your whole community
on launch for the launch of
the book on BelieveIt.com.
So giving a course away
and a 95 page action plan
that helps you implement all the lessons
from the book in real life.
And Gary, it's really a book
for anyone who just is
struggling with self doubt
and wants to know how
to truly like go from
not believing themselves
to believing in themselves.
So it's called Believe It.
And everything's on BelieveIt.com.
- Jamie, do you believe
that had you failed as an elderly woman,
you would have been thrilled
because at least you went for it?
- Yes, yes.
- That's were I want to
go with this everyone.
This is the bow on this
or maybe the cherry on
this very nice cake.
I think what's incredibly
important in James' message
is that part.
You may be sitting.
I love what she's doing.
She communicates like I do.
She's trying to get into
the psyche and saying, look,
I get it.
You're two years in.
You're like, I believe it.
I believe it.
Well, we don't know because
many of you fall into this camp.
There are people who believe it.
And then there are people
who genuinely are so not
self-aware that they're delusional.
And they think they're gonna
be professional athletes
when they can't run or they can't jump.
That happens.
And that's not fun for me to say,
but what I think is even
if you aren't destined
for this massive success,
it's still a bigger win,
whether you're delusional
or you believe it.
I still think at 75, at 95 at
103, you're going to be pumped
that you went for it because
you won't have regret Jame.
- Yeah.
I have goosebumps right now.
That's everything.
- You agree with that?
- I agree.
That's everything.
- All right, everybody,
please pick up the book.
As you can tell by my energy,
I'm excited about it.
I'm sorry I had to cut it a hair short.
That is just the reality of my life,
but I'm sure Jamie will be on the circuit.
So go Google her and find her
in other podcasts and
things of that nature.
And we thank you.
And I'm stealing one
32nd moment for myself,
which I rarely do.
So I'm going to do that.
Bye everybody, Jamie, thank you so much.
BelieveIt.com.
Go check it out.
Get the freebies with the book.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
YouTube watcher, what's up?
It's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to explode.
Stories, polls,
more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon